this is a production of cornell
university
thanks charlie and anna for the intro
i'm happy to be talking about some of my
work looking at plyotropy within mace
and so
[Music]
um to start us off i think it's helpful
to define what plyotropy is and its
simplest form plyotropy is a single
locus that affects multiple traits and
it can happen through a bunch of
different mechanisms
of which you have a single causal
variant that's a star and you have a
single causal variant that impacts two
different traits um or two causal
variants within the same gene that then
affect two different traits there's also
mediated or vertical plyotropy where
that single causal variant impacts one
trait which then subsequently impacts
another
and then probably most commonly is
spurious plyotrophy where you have a
region of really strong ld making it
hard to ascertain which causal variant
is impacting your two traits of interest
and so within human disease plyotrophy
is a really common feature with up to 44
of the genes in the human geovos catalog
showing plyotropy and of those
plyotropic sites they've been associated
with higher and wider gene expression
across more tissues
they've been enriched in open chromatin
regions and then also shown some dna
conservation
and so within mace there's a few
examples of like cloned or verified
plyotropy out there
and now these are teosinte branched one
that impacts inflorescence length
lateral branching and branch length
along with a vgt-1 that impacts plant
height
leaf number and flowering time
and so there's the kind of this
assumption in the early 2010s that with
more genotypes and with more phenotypes
and association mapping that we'd be
able to find more plyotropy and so this
is one of the first stabs of that
looking at uh pliotropic inflorescence
trades and flowering time and found that
essentially there were no shared loci
between all three traits however there
was some sharing between tassel and ear
traits
or things sharing the same like
developmental units or pathways
there's also some plyotropy between
tassel and flowering traits
and most of the the plyotrophy that's
present between flowering leaf has to do
with
maize making sure it has the right
number of leaves before it initiates
flowering time
and so more recently a paper came out a
few weeks ago looking at plyotropy
across 162 different maze traits
and very very few of those snips
genome-wide actually do show plyotropy
and of those are between traits that we
would kind of already expect to share
loci like flowering time with a
leaf architecture or flowering time and
inflorescence architecture traits very
rarely do we see sharing between like
flowering time and root genes which is
unexpected
and so it kind of leads us to this
question but why is there so much more
plyotropy in human disease
compared to maize
and so a couple of key limitations that
might be biasing how much plyotropy that
we're seeing
is that we're mostly looking for
plyotropy within maze mutants versus
standing natural variation populations
and a lot of these plyotropic profiles
assessed through large effect mutations
may really differ from these small
effect larger populations
also gwas models in maize historically
had low resolution and so trying to
determine which is the causal sniff from
many candidates still remains elusive
and also results may vary by the model
that you use the types of covariates the
types of traits that you select
significant thresholds and plyo trophy
statistics and so with all that together
we wanted to ask how explainable is
plyotropic and maize through a bunch of
different metrics the first thing that
we need to know is is there any
variability in plyotropy whatsoever and
if so can we potentially bring in the
things that were important in human
genetic studies like gene expression dna
accessibility dna conservation and then
also add in statistically interfering
variables that we know impact ul studies
like the amount of ld and the number of
snips that we use to map those traits
and so all together this kind of builds
a really cool model that we can then
test to see how plyotropy is impacted
and controlled within mace
and so in order to do that we use two
existing mapping populations the nested
association mapping panel or nam and the
goodman panel
and with our help with all the
phenotypes that are already available in
these populations
is we would get phenotypic saturation in
order to uncover the genome-wide
distributions of plyotropic loci across
the central dogma of traits
and so we're starting around with 32
million traits between our two
populations
rna expression values from seven diverse
tissues metabolite features and then
field features like flowering time plant
height and fluorescence architecture
and so this is what our overall pipeline
looks like where we have our different
populations
our different trait types and then also
the number of traits that we're mapping
with we then perform gwas with
within those populations
and then aggregate those results by
interval and so for example here we have
74 000 intervals genome-wide
and our unique trait snips associations
are those different shapes and so for
interval a
we have two unique traits mapping to it
so we mark it as two for interval b we
have one unique trait mapping to it so
we count it as one we do that for the
rest of the intervals genome-wide and so
then we get a count of the number of
unique traits that map to each interval
genome-wide and so in order to get
something to compare these counts with
what we do is we permute all of our
phenotypes anywhere from five to ten
times run them to the same exact
pipeline
in order to get a null distribution of
what no plyotrophy looks like whatsoever
and so
i will note before i start showing some
plots that um
our plyotrophy is a single genic or
energetic interval that can affect
multiple traits and we don't distinguish
between what type of plyotrophy we're
looking for so it's any one of these
mechanisms that could potentially be
happening
and so
before i show you the plot i want to
describe what you're going to see and so
along the x-axis is going to be the bin
number of traits that are mapped to that
particular interval
and so it could be anywhere from zero to
a few thousand traits and along the
y-axis is the permuted minus original
proportion of intervals that fall in
that trait number category
that's kind of confusing so anything
along the horizontal line means that
there's no plyotropy and then anything
above means also it's noise probably not
plyo trophy at all compared to the
permuted data
and anything below the line means that
there's some plyotropy that's promising
to look into so with that
this is just showing the results
for the namm field data
and this bump right here is probably a
region of strong ld
com and probably just noise altogether
but there is this little promising bump
that might show some plyotropy
that has anywhere from like 30 to 90
traits mapping to it i will say that the
number of intervals showing this trend
is on the fraction of a percent
genome-wide so it's a very very rare
occurrence
and also i don't collapse on unique
traits so i can have multiple versions
of flowering time represented in this
plot across different environments
but still there's something interesting
here
and so looking across populations and
different trait types these
distributions change wildly and so
the goodman field traits which is in the
top right hand side
there's significantly less flyotrophy
but there's still some there for a very
small number of
intervals and traits
and then for the goodman uh metabolites
and expression there's very very little
plyotrophy whatsoever and it's on the
fraction of a percentage of intervals
genome-wide that show this trend
and so now that we know that there is
variability in plyo trophy we can go
forward and build models to try to
explain this
and so um
what we do is take all those biological
features from before and then run a
model with our flyotropy statistic
and so this is our random forest results
where along the x-axis is relative
importance and along the y-axis is all
the different features that we use to
build our model and so everything in
blue are statistical features and gray
is biological and so
um the most important features overall
are all of our statistical things like
the amount of ld
the number of snips that we use in the
interval size and a very low importance
or all of our biological terms like
expression like conservation and so on
and if we look across populations we see
pretty much the same trend of there's
very little importance of all of our
biological terms compared to our
statistical terms
and so that kind of leads us to say that
biotrophy is not really associated with
many biological features
within maze and so i will note even
though i don't have time to show it
today we did create an adjusted
plyotrophy statistic removing all the
variants from those
statistical terms
and still found the same relationship of
gene expression accessibility and
conservation isn't associated with
plyotropy compared to the permuted data
and so
um to kind of conclude things
we hypothesize that plyotrophy is not
common in nase and of the few plyotropic
loci that do exist
they can come from sites with varying
amounts of gene expression chromatin
accessibility and sequence conservation
also plyodropine crop plants is highly
constrained by evolution and this kind
of makes sense because the independence
of trades is essential if you're going
to adapt new varieties to new
environments and that's especially true
out in the wild then also within
breeding programs independence is nice
to have
and also results still may vary by the
type of the species that you use
the types of traits that you look at the
marker resolution and saturation and of
course not having a robust null to
actually compare all of your results to
which we have here
and with that i'd like to say thanks my
i am funded off of a usda nifa
fellowship along with some other grants
within the lab and i'd like to say
thanks to a bunch of the folks in my lab
and happy to take questions
there's a question online
uh great talk biologically we can
anticipate that many genes are
cliotropic through regulating
development of plant phytomers
can you developmentally biologically
interpret results and observations that
are obtained from statistical
associations
i
developmentally well i guess to kind of
answer your question um
we do do some like go enrichment just
look at the types of genes that might be
i guess highly plyotropic but i'm not
sure if that answers your question if
you could follow up with me that would
be great
john
luke uh great talk yes you started out
with the question of why is made so
different from humans but you didn't
give an answer
i think it's
selection
different types of selection and the
bias in human genetics to study diseases
and we're not necessarily looking at
those same types of traits and they
might have different genetic
architectures control or they do have
different genetic architectures
i think yeah with diseases where bias is
studying things that are wrong not
necessarily things like
more quantitative like other plant
traits yeah
yeah anna
um
selection of your keto types
actually used like
um
[Applause]
yeah
i think it is really biased and i think
that's
been kind of like addressed in some
papers in that if you're just looking at
components of the same trait or like
ratios of metabolites that are all
highly related they probably will show
more plyotropy because they have yeah a
shared regulatory pathway and so yeah
trade selection really does matter in
something like this where it looks more
prevalent but across many many more
things it's not necessarily a common
phenomenon
yeah
okay rebecca what's your question um
maybe it's
as related to jean-luc but yeah thanks
also for for a great talk and um
i'm wondering i mean surely there's
other data about humans that's more
analogous to the types of data about a
plant that you're mentioning so it seems
funny to me to compare human disease
versus corn anything and so i'm
wondering if
if what does human anything get you in
the way of plyo trophy and then what if
we look at plant you know corn disease
as a corn pathologist of course i can't
help wondering and i i think there's a
lot of player trophy about other traits
that affect diseases via that indirect
type of cliotrophy presumably so
just curious if any has anybody looked
at it other than disease and what is the
analogous question really to make those
two comparisons actually more analogous
you know
how would you set it up because
i i'm unsatisfied by disease versus
other you know as a comparison
yeah yeah
i i should mention that it's not only in
human disease where plyo trophies come
and there are other traits that they've
they've looked at and seen a little bit
more plyotrophy than normal i think
disease is where it's most pronounced
and also gets the most
funding and papers which is little pious
but yeah um
yeah i'm not sure what an equivalent
version of this would look like in maize
maybe disease yes um yeah because we
look at how how do for a larger yeah the
field traits influence the ability of
fungi to colonize that ear and produce
toxins you know for example but i think
[Music]
anyway
do i still have time for another
question thanks rebecca
okay yes john luke if you could
re-explain your robust null that would
be helpful for me sure um so what we did
was essentially uh permuted all of our
phenotypes anywhere from five to ten
times and then we removed the the
variability from the pcs that still
might be holding population structure
and then use those like pc-adjusted
phenotypes as our new phenotypes and
then map those
so yeah
does that answer your question okay
alrighty hello everyone my name is elise
tomaszewski and today i'm going to have
a discussion about the approaches that
i've taken to try and understand the
regulation of fruit obsession in
fistulous grasa
so fissile squasea can be characterized
as a solanaceae crop that has a
sprawling growth habit and an
indeterminate growth habit as well
meaning that the plant continues to
produce fruit and mature them throughout
the entirety of its life cycle
so these fruit are about the size of a
grape tomato they have the flavor
profile of a cross between a mango and a
pineapple so pretty sweet and also tart
and fistless grasaea is part of a genus
of around a hundred different species
but it is closely related to pepper and
then also related to tomato as well so
it is part of the solanaceae family
so to get everyone oriented on the
fistulous floral anatomy i'd like
everyone to look on the right here which
is part of the thistles flower we have
the petals here
the stigma and styles and a structure
called the calyx or sepal which
surrounds the flower
and then we also have a pedestal which
is kind of like a stalk that connects
the flower to the plant
once the flower is then pollinated a
globe-like fruit will then be produced
and surrounded by this calyx or a husk
is what it's normally called
something that's interesting is that a
lot of people think it's the flower that
is surrounding the fruit but in fact it
is this calyx and on this bottom left
here you can see that the petals are
actually pushed down towards the end of
the calyx
but the part that i'll be talking about
most here is the pedestal and this is
where the abscission zone forms and
where the fruit detaches from the plant
so what is obsession there's three main
types of obsession that i'll be talking
about briefly in this part and one that
i'll be talking about the rest of my
talk so the first one here is leaf
obsession this is characterized mostly
you can see around ithaca in the fall
when leaves are falling off of deciduous
trees
you also have flower abscission where
unpollinated apple blossoms will abort
from the plant due to limited starch and
sugar allocation
and then fruit obsession is where i'm
mostly interested in this is beneficial
for the plant because it'll allow for
seed dispersal however while most
incision is beneficial for the plant
agronomically this is not the case and
the fact that when you're dropping fruit
it is unsellable and you cannot have a
profit then as a farmer also you'll have
increased labor for trying to clean up
this fruit or increase uh harvest time
losing out on profit again
so i'm using fistless gerseya twofold
one is a model to understand how fruit
obsession is regulated both spatially
and temporally and i'm trying to figure
out what is specific about fruit
precision where you know when you're
dropping your fruit you aren't also
dropping all of your leaves at the same
time that's not beneficial for the plant
at all
on the other hand i'm trying to reduce
abscission in fistless to make it a more
agronomically viable crop for farmers
i'd also like to point out here that
fistless garcia drops its fruit while
other plants do not and what i mean by
this is that tomato will have this
obsidian incision zone that forms on the
pedestal as well but it's not raining
fruit kind of like how fistless does
so to get everyone oriented exactly on
what obsession is here's a hypothesized
model that i've created to outline the
four different steps of abscission the
first here and what i will be showing is
the petiole which is outlined from a
hypothesized tomato plant on the left
you can imagine that the fruit would be
attached and then on the right the
petiole would be attached to the plant
and i use pedial and pedestal
interchangeably just so you know
and within the petiole a few layers of
cells called the obsession zone cells
which are characterized as small cyto
cytoplasmically dense cells form and
then after that these cells have to
become competent to external regulations
such as plant hormones like ethylene or
aba which then induce cell separation by
dissolving the middle lamella as well as
degrading the cell walls
and then after that the plant then
produces a form of lignin shown on the
left side of the fruit side of the
petiole here to act as a mechanical
barrier to kind of help set up the plant
where this break should happen
and then the abscission zone cells on
the plant side of the petiole then
confer some sort of epidermal like
qualities and they produce a cuticle to
act as a protective layer
so i'll be talking today about a couple
of genes that i'm targeting specifically
for steps one and four to try and reduce
oxygen in physilis
so to do that i am using a reverse
genetics approach to knock out different
genes looking at the literature of what
has been done before in closely related
species like tomato as well as
arabidopsis and lychee
so the three genes of interest that i'll
be talking about today are j
macro calix and ida which is downstream
of obscene zone development but what i'd
like to point out here is that j and
macrocalyx are mad box transcription
factors which in the literature have
been found to interact and form protein
complexes with other madbox
transcription factors and in this case
they are developing the obsidian zone
cells or inducing oxygen zone
development
so i will be targeting these to
hopefully knock them out and then reduce
any abscission zone formation
so the first gene that i will be talking
about today is j which is the homologue
of jointless in tomato so j's and
fistless jointlessness and tomato it is
a madsbox transcription factor which
regulates floral organ development
joint list ii which is the homolog of
jointless and tomato there's a lot of
homolog going on here
creates this joint over when it's
knocked out does not have a joint so
however this uh homolog does not exist
in thistles crusade that would be my
first choice as it's used a lot in the
commercial variants but that does not
exist in this list so i'm going to
jointless to see if i can knock on an
incision zone which this diagram shows
here on the left a wild type pedestal
where a joint or a knuckle is formed
where the fruit will detach from the
plant and then on the right when the
jointless gene is knocked out you do not
have any joint formation so hopefully
that is going to happen with my fistless
plants
so i've been able to transform using a
crispr construct that i've designed to
knock out the j-gene and physilis i've
been able to take them out of culture
and i now have t-zero plants that are
growing in the greenhouse where i'll be
able to collect fruit self them to
hopefully t3 or t4 generations and look
for any differences in incision zone
cell formation as well as any other
effects of knocking out this gene
the next gene i'll be talking about
today is mpf3 which is the homologue of
macrocalyx in tomato again it is a
madbox transcription factor and in
tomato has been thought to interact with
j so i'm hoping to knock out multiple
parts of this protein complex that is
theorized
in this case in tomato when you knock
out this gene you have both large
calyces which are shown in the diagram
on the top right compared to the wild
type
but it also interacts with j so you
aren't forming an obsession zone so on
the left here you have an abscission
zone and the wild type and then on the
right this line of demarcation is not
there so there's an incomplete obsession
zone being formed so i'm also hoping to
knock this out and i do have t3 lines
now and find that the homozygous mutants
do not drop their fruit as much as the
wild type compared on the right here i
would like to notice or point out though
that there is a an incision of the fruit
later on but it does seem delayed
i'd also like to point out here that the
size of the pedestals between the wild
type and the mutant shown the wild type
on the top and the mutant pedestals on
the bottom have a very clear size
distinction so the mutants being much
larger but they do have this obscene
zone you can sort of see it as a white
line in the middle of the pedestal so
i'm interested to keep looking at how
this is affected on the cellular level
and then the last gene that i'll be
talking about today is inflorescence
deficient in abscission it's been
characterized in arabidopsis and lychee
for floral develop or floral obsession
as well as fruit abscission and lychee
but it is a peptide ligand that binds to
leucine-rich receptors that induces a
cascade to induce
upregulation of cell separation genes so
that's step three four that i'm talking
about with my hypothesis of the obscene
zone model
so the first row on the top here is wild
type arabidopsis flowers and the bottom
is what i'd like everyone to focus on as
well with a knockout of ida we can see
here that around stage nine in the wild
type it's dropping all of its floral
organs where when you knock out this
gene in arabidopsis the petals remain
attached to the plant this doesn't mean
that there's not an obscision zone it
just means that the cell separation has
not been able to occur so i'm hoping to
knock this out and i've been able to
create another crispr construct
and i now have these in culture and i'm
hopefully hopefully going to have them
progress along
so i'm very excited to get this talk a
year from now and hopefully i'll have
more going on i have a lot more projects
that i'm currently doing such as an
rna-seq project looking at a
developmental series to understand
differentially expressed genes within
the obsession zone to hopefully target
them
i'm also looking more at microscopy to
have a quantifiable way to show that
there's a difference between the
abscission zone cells within my mutants
and my biotype as well as using force
measurements as a way to quantify any
differences between the mutants and the
wild type so the detachment force is
what i'm looking at here
and then lastly one of the other ones
i'm trying to do is then create double
and triple mute so crossing my mpf3 and
my j mutants as they're part of matt's
box transcription factor pathways and
see what this does also to the obsession
zone development
so i'd like to acknowledge all of my
committee members joyce fanec jim
giovannoni and adrienne roeder as well
as especially the van ack lab
specifically savannah dale kerry
swartwood and nathan green who is a
former postdoc for all of their
continued health
and i would be happy to take questions
and also give recipes if you'd like
[Applause]
yes
fantastic
thank you
can you mention that you like ruled out
journalists
[Music]
right now that's a good point so i
blasted the genes that's how i've done
it before and i've been able to find
jointless or mpf3 and i didn't see
anything that had high homology between
jointless ii and any gene within
fistulas our reference genome is quite
new um but i do think it would i believe
within the literature there is no
jointless two within arabidopsis either
so this might be a specific
thing to tomato to have this jointless
two and interacting in a protein complex
yes
um
right and yeah i couldn't get it into my
talk but i'm really looking at a dosage
effect in a way so having kind of this
intermediate phenotype of an incision
zone right now i'm using it as a model
i'm trying to figure out what these
genes do at first but i would expect
them to break off so you have the
substitution zone on the pedestal but
you also have an abscission zone where
the fruit connects to the calyx see if i
can quickly go back
okay so you also have an abscission zone
by the fruit with the calyx so i would
expect there to be um the subcision zone
where the pedestal and the calix
connects so it's kind of like tomato
where when you break it off in jointless
tomatoes the seep or the pedestal and
the sepals remain on the plant but you
just get the fruit which is advantageous
then so you're not having a bunch of
poked fruit due to the pedestal so
that's what i would expect
cool yes
i haven't yet and some of the mutants
i've seen some splitting on the bottom
um of the fruit itself but that's pretty
uncommon in wild type and all the
mutants that i've had i haven't seen
that yet so
no but i'll keep an eye out for it too
okay thank you
thanks charlie um hi everyone today i'm
going to talk about one of my projects
examining effects of the manny hope
glazio vi integration in cassava
so cassava breeders in the 1930s were
facing a disease epidemic of cassava
mosaic disease and to try to combat this
they were breeding for
disease resistance by making crosses
with cassava's wild relative many hope
plasiovi
and
progeny from some of those crosses
became important founders in modern
breeding germ plaza
so the legacy of that is that there are
two large integration segments from many
hope glossier vi on chromosomes one and
four in cassava and so you can see in
green and blue the introduction segments
um on the last 10 megabases of
chromosome 1 and the central 20 megabase
pairs of chromosome 4
increase in frequency
as cycles of selection proceed
and so um the introduction is becoming
an increasingly important part of
the population structure
and so previous work in our lab by
martin wolf at all looked at how the
chromosome 1 integration
affects root number and dry matter
percentage which affects
yield as well as the textural properties
of cassava roots and so what's
interesting is that the chromosome 1
integration doesn't seem to be affecting
variability for disease resistance but
it does impact these important yield
traits
however they also found that there's
suppressed recombination in the
integration region so the integration
tends to be inherited as a big block
and that makes it difficult to break
unfavorable linkages in this region and
it also limits the resolution for us to
tell what's going on with the qtl in
this region
and
in addition
we find that there are almost no
homozygous introgressed lines and
advanced trials so we see homozygous
introgress lines in early stage trials
but they get selected against very
quickly
and martin hypothesized that this might
be due to deleterious mutations that
have accumulated in the integration
region and so breeders have to maintain
the integration in the heterozygous
state which is somewhat costly because
whenever you cross two lines that are
integra are heterozygous for the
integration a quarter of your progeny
will be homozygous into progressed and
then automatically
are unlikely to be advanced
so i'm interested in following up on
this work by
looking into what are the negative
effects of homozygosity in integration
in particular um are there are they
localized to particular segments or are
deleterious alleles spread throughout
the introduction region
and then also with increased resolution
can we narrow in on the yield qtl and
identify which segments
contain this yield qtl and see if we can
select only the segments that
contain the yield qtl while purging the
deleterious load that's carried by the
rest of the integration
so to generate higher resolution for
this qtl analysis we started by making
crosses to generate recombinations in
the introduction
and
we then
screened the progeny with cast markers
which was a way to
look at just the integration genotypes
of many individuals
and then we evaluated these individuals
for vigor which
i hypothesized might be
a
effect of homozygosity and integration
that they would have poorer fitness or
vigor
and then we use these genotypes to
select a subset to advance to replicated
trials where we can evaluate yields
and finally i'm working on evaluating
associations between particular
integration segments and these yield and
bigger traits
so this is the ceiling nursery that came
from those crosses and so
this was growing at the international
institute of tropical agriculture in
ibadan nigeria
and it was the crosses were made and and
planted by a team led by dr robbie and
smith at iata
and i got to visit this
field over the summer and
um
there's so the crosses were made between
41 parents that were heterozygous for
the integration so there are 259
families
and while i was there i evaluated vigor
both in plant height and stem diameter
which are two components of what makes a
plant look vigorous to a breeder
and i also collected leaf samples so
that we could screen this population for
their integration genotypes
and so to screen many individuals in a
cost effective way we use a panel of 10
past markers
so cast markers
have a competitive primers that bind to
a bilix snip so for this panel i chose
glassy ovi specific snips that i
identified from a panel of 118
accessions
from cassava hat map 2 that either had
the introduction or lacked it
and
identified 10 of these snips across
integrations based about one megabase
per part
and we validated the snips using the
parents which were already genotyped as
well as a set of wild glossier vi trees
and hybrids between espogenta and blasio
va
and you can see from the diamonds that
those wild and hybrid individuals
clustered where we would expect them to
in the homozygous and heterozygous
genotype classes
so with those 10 markers we can get a
granular view of the integration
genotype for the individuals in the
ceiling nursery on the y-axis across the
10 casper markers on chromosome one in
the integration region spaced about one
megabase fair apart and so for example
you can see
one individual
here
lacks integration on this half and the
pink and it's homozygous for the
integration on this half and dark blue
and so we were able to observe
recombinations between each of the
marker pairs and so between 11 and 358
recombinations between each pair
but you'll notice that there are fewer
homozygous intragress individuals in
dark blue than there are homozygous
non-introgress individuals in pink
and so to test if that was significant
we did a chi-square test to test if the
genotype distribution was significantly
different from the one to two to one
ratio that you'd expect from making
crosses with heterozygous parents
and we saw that it was significant there
was fewer
homozygous glossier vi lines than you'd
expect so this could indicate that there
is some kind of seedling or seed
viability or early survival issue with
the homozygous lines
and this is just for cast marker one
that i'm showing but we saw the same
pattern that was significant across all
ten
markers so next to look at if homozygote
integration affects plant bigger so here
i'm showing stem diameter as a measure
of vigor
and broken out by the genotypes across
the 10 gas markers
and i saw that the heterozygous
intragress lines in light blue
had slightly higher stem diameter than
the homozygous lines
and to test if that was significant i
used a mixed linear model for stem
diameter with
the additive and dominant effect for
each marker accounting for
family and field position with random
effects
and i saw that
several markers had significant effects
on for some diameter
and so
the effect sizes for those markers for
stem diameter
is significant you can see for markers 3
and 6 through 10. so the dominance
effect is significant and so that
explains that the heterozygote has a
slightly higher stem diameter than the
homozygotes but none of the additive
effects are significant so it doesn't
explain why the homozygote it doesn't
explain that the homozygous ovi line is
any worse necessarily than the
homozygote escalante lines
so um returning to this question why are
homozygote lines and why are
introgressed homozygotes excluded from
advanced
trials
it looks like glossier classic vi
alleles have um statistically
significant but quite small effects on
vigor so
going back to this you can see that all
the effect sizes are
between 0.25 and 0.5 millimeters so it's
quite a small difference in some
diameter
so it seems like that could be
contributing a small amount but
it's definitely not fully explaining why
we almost never see homozygous
introgress individuals in later stages
so i'm thinking that the segregation
distortion we observed as well as
possible impacts on yield maybe more
important factors in explaining um
what's going on with the negative
effects of homozygosity and integration
and so to evaluate yield next um we
needed to select 300 individuals from
the population of about 3 000 that would
represent the genetic diversity present
in the integration ceiling nursery
so that we can replicate those
individuals and get better measurements
for their yield and clonal trials
and so to pick the 300 from the 3000
i used an optimal design algorithm with
the opt better off package in r
and so this algorithm picks a subset of
individuals that captures the maximum
amount of information about the marker
effects and the parent effects
and so
these are the genotypes from the 300
selected clones and you can see that
they're enriched for the recombinant
individuals so it's providing more
information about the independent
effects of the markers
and so next this clone evaluation trial
is growing now at iita and i will return
in august to for harvest season to look
at the yield traits from this trial
and we're also doing whole genome um
dart seek genotypes for these
individuals so i'll be able to look at
rest of genome effect versus integration
marker effects rather than just having a
parent effect
so hopefully that will give us more
information about isolating the effect
of the integration versus background
and i also want to follow up on the
segregation distortion that i observed
and see if there are structural variants
in the introgression region that might
be explaining that
with that i'd like to thank my committee
members the buckler lab for sharing
because i have a hot map data with me as
well as our collaborators at iata who
have set up the trials and helped me in
the field and made it possible for me to
study this population thank you
[Applause]
the question was is germination rate
scored and it is not that something that
we
thought about doing at the beginning is
having a germination experiment where we
try to genotype the seeds that do not
germinate
um and
um
yeah we didn't proceed with that because
it
um
it's somewhat difficult to get seeds
here and it's a bit
it's a quite labor intensive to do that
and figure out how to extract dna from
the seeds that didn't germinate um at
iata and since i'm
here for most of the year um
it wasn't feasible for me to do that
project there
but i think it is um
we did try and genotype
as early on in the
season as possible to capture
um
as many of the genotypes as we could
but from visual observations
or when you say failure to germinate
whether it's like 10 or 20 of these
i don't have an estimate on the
percentage of seeds that that
didn't germinate but i think in general
it's quite high for cassava
for any specific cross um where i think
it's maybe 75 50 to 75 percent of the
seeds germinate um
yeah in general
yeah so stem diameter is not typically
looked at in the breeding trials what is
scored for vigor is a three five seven
scale for vigor which is somewhat
relative
to where seven is the best in the field
and three is the worst for vigor so when
i was there i wanted to get a more
quantitative measurement for vigor and
so i talked to breeders about
what um parameters they're actually
looking at to figure out if something is
a seven or three um and something that
came out of that was that thicker stems
and taller plants
contribute to being scored a seven
versus a three and so that's the traits
that i decided to measure and some
diameter is not typically measured so
i will be able to see
i have some
early yield measurements from the
seedling nursery they're not that
reliable because there's no replicates
but the stem diameter was correlated
with yield in that
trial but i think we'll have to wait to
see how the replicated
trial looks between the correlation of
some diameter and yield to know if it's
correlated with yields but in general
the above ground plant biomass doesn't
always correlate with the below ground
yield
thanks
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu